Let's go to the phones, by which I mean the
Dischord Lines, as we often do on Fridays,
you can find The David Pakman Show discord
at David Pakman dot com slash discord,
get into the waiting lobby if
you would like to talk to me.
Let's start today with Dylan from Kentucky.
Dylan, you're on the air. What's going on?
Hey, David, can you hear me? Yes, I
can
a yeah, I wanted to specifically talk a little
bit about the vaccine and some of the rhetoric
around what we can do after we get it. So I know
that we've that you've talked a little bit about
being able to gather if everyone is vaccinated.
Right.
But but what what is the difference between
saying, hey, we can have small gatherings
of people who are all vaccinated and say, you
know, a large gathering of everyone that is
vaccinated? Because isn't that a localized herd
immunity? I think we need to be more optimistic
about the vaccine.
Yeah. I mean, I think that
your point is a crazy one, which is with
vaccines that are 65 to 95 percent effective.
If you have all vaccinated people in a room,
whether it's four people, six people or 20 people,
the odds of having both a vaccinated person
that somehow got it and then then giving it
to another vaccinated person who somehow will
get it. Obviously, you're talking about low
percentages here, but I do think it makes sense
to go in steps. And the other thing is most states
right now have limits on the size of gathering's
anyway. Sometimes it's 10, sometimes it's 20. So
once you say that the number for the size
of gatherings is different for vaccinated
versus unvaccinated, it starts to get
kind of complicated anyway. So for me,
it makes sense. If you're vaccinated, get together
in a small group and you don't have to wear masks
if you're in a person's home in many states
that are still mask mandates. So if you're out,
you might be in a store or wherever where you
have to wear a mask anyway. And if there's going
to be unvaccinated people, the unvaccinated
people should all be from one household.
It all makes sense to me. But I agree with
you that these vaccines are really good.
And what's safe for vaccinated
people
probably is a bit beyond what the CDC has
said so far. I don't disagree with you there.
OK, yeah, that's yeah, I mean,
I guess, you know, there's some
hesitancy still around the vaccine and I even saw
an article yesterday about, you know, even once
you get the vaccine, nothing really changes.
Yeah, I think it's bad. I've said I've done
a bunch of clips where if you're telling people
nothing changes, why would people get vaccinated?
I think it makes sense to be clear and say things
do change. It becomes very unlikely you will get
the disease. If you were to get it, it becomes
almost a zero percent chance that you will get
it seriously. The Israeli data is it reduces
transmission. You can hang out and hug and
be without masks with vaccinated people. Yeah, I
think it makes sense to be very clear that there's
a lot that changes actually. And the more people
that get it, the more quickly it will change.
Right, right. All right, yeah, that's
that's the main thing I wanted to bring
up just because I feel like there needs to
be a higher amount of optimism around. Yes.
And I don't see that happening right now.
I agree. I think it's happening more. And
the CDC guidelines were good. And I think soon
we'll probably get more more updates on those
guidelines. But we need more more of the optimism
for sure. These are game changing vaccines.
Right. All right, David, I appreciate it.
All right. Thank you. Great to hear from you.
Always, always love hearing from folks from
all states. From all states. Let's go next
to Freddy from Tampa, Freddy
from Tampa. You're on the air.
Freddy from Tampa, please, on mute, you're
on the air. Hey, good
afternoon, David Pakman. How are
you? I'm doing well, thank you.
I don't have a political question. I wanted
to ask you, what's your favorite movie?
Oh, I
don't have a single favorite, but
that's like saying, what's your favorite book? You
know how. I don't know. I'm not a huge movie guy,
but I couldn't possibly my favorite single
movie. I don't know. I mean, the you know,
the land before time still gets me. I've
loved that one since I was a kid, but now I
don't I don't know. Thank you so
much. I love your show. Thanks.
All right. My pleasure. Sorry, I don't have a you
know, something people say, what's your favorite
book? And it's like, I don't know.
You know, I'm reading
three books every two weeks.
It's it's really hard to say.